foreign
hi everyone thanks for having me Simone
great to have you here on um what has
not been a very dull couple of weeks for
crypto
um so let's get straight into it um just
a reminder to the members please um feel
free to submit your questions via the Q
a
um and then we will come to them so I'm
going to get us started
um about going down this rabbit hole
that is crypto so first question to you
Laura is how did you fall into the
crypto rabbit hole
back in 2015 I was a journalist covering
personal finance actually and I was a
contributor at Forbes and I had been
covering that for a few years and I
frankly was getting a little ready to
move on to something new I wasn't
learning a lot of new things and my
editors didn't want me to necessarily
leave the section for some other section
so they said hey we have this idea what
if we do a Forbes fintech 50 list and
you can head up the list with another
reporter so she and I divided it into
different categories and I took the
category of digital currencies and I
just became completely obsessed and here
I am seven and a half years later still
just as obsessed as ever and loving it
right well it's definitely a great thing
to be in right now so
um
that begs the question for me so how is
sort of fintech different to to crypto
because a lot of people sort of Define
it as you know crypto sort of like magic
beams or magic internet money that is
kind of pulled out of thin air so so
what is crypto and and how would you
explain it in the simplest terms to you
know my parents let's say
so fintech is what I would call a
digital veneer on the decades-old
existing Financial system that has been
around kind of like from the 70s you
could say the pipes of that system
uh were created then and crypto is a
completely new technology it's like
leapfrogging it's it's just something
fundamentally different
and with
um you know fintech you know when you
look at your venmo or whatever what's
happening in the background it might
look slick and it might seem fast but
what's happening in the background is
still kind of the same slow
um basically frankly inefficient way of
managing finances whereas crypto is kind
of a little bit more real time and
um yeah uses uh basically fancy
cryptography and
um is truly digital at its core whereas
fintech is you could imagine it's more
like almost like a paper version that
they just have you know a kind of a
digital
um version of uh whereas like I said
with crypto
um the money is inherently digital it's
not like paper money where we have a
digital representation
right and you you truly believe that
crypto is the future despite everything
that's happening right now
I would say so in the sense that just in
the course of my own lifetime if I look
at how I use the phone
you know when I was young I used to
pick up a corded phone sometimes
attached to a wall
you know drive my parents Crazy by being
on it at all hours and talking to my
friends forever and then they you know
they couldn't be on it I mean we did
call waiting didn't even exist when I
was little right and if I look today at
well my phone does now I mean come on
it's just you know it's my camera and um
you know I can message people I can
email people I can do my finances I can
write like hold documents in there so
um you know I feel that when you have
something that is technologically
Superior it's really only a matter of
time before it it wins out and of course
I understand yes betamax didn't win over
VHS but still regardless like that
technology became adopted even if maybe
the the best version of it didn't win
out
so in the not too distant future we're
going to start to see different
utilities that we don't currently see
from crypto
yeah yeah and I think we're already
seeing that you know whether or not you
think they're valuable is a different
question but
um certainly just in the seven and a
half years I've covered this I've seen
completely new things that have not been
witnessed before in history be enabled
by crypto
um so
what do you think because obviously
right now crypto has a little bit of a
bad rap there's a lot going on
um what do you think the biggest
misconception is about cryptocurrency
so I would say actually that the first
one probably is that it is a currency
the reason why that kind of general term
is used is because the very first crypto
asset was a currency which is Bitcoin
and so when I use that more general term
crypto assets what I'm saying is that
you can have similar
um you know uh items that aren't
currencies and so let's just take the
two most popular these one is Bitcoin
and the other is ether
so with Bitcoin as we just mentioned it
was designed to be like a currency and
it actually has a few different
attributes and one other thing that I
want to educate people on is that
there's actually two things that are
named Bitcoin first the network the
blockchain is Bitcoin with a capital B
usually uh that's the typical style and
that is The Ledger that enables people
to see all the Bitcoin transactions
since the moment that the Bitcoin
blockchain was launched
and the uh Bitcoin with a lowercase b is
Bitcoin the asset which is that currency
and when you look at the um Bitcoin
white paper that's when you kind of can
understand that most people think of
Bitcoin as just those coins you know
that have value and it's this currency
but actually the subtitle of the Bitcoin
white papers is um it says an electronic
peer-to-peer cache system or sorry what
a peer-to-peer electronic cash system
and so
um that's really referring to bitcoin
the blockchain or Bitcoin the network
and um ethereum in ethereum it's like a
little bit easier to to uh to make this
differentiation because ethereum the
network is called ethereum the asset
itself is called ether
now to go into why it is that Bitcoin is
a cryptocurrency versus why ether is a
different type of crypto asset I'll just
very simply explain
Bitcoin is designed as
um it has a limited supply of 21 million
coins and because it was meant to be
this electronic peer-to-peer electronic
cache that is you know what we would
consider a currency except electronic
right and so
um you know what Satoshi was going for
really was like money however the fact
is that because of the 21 million coin
limit it is true that nowadays most
people probably use Bitcoin more as a
form of what they call store of value or
digital gold
um because you've probably heard the
stories there are people who you know
bought uh like the most famous example
is somebody who was the first person to
ever spend or actually he didn't spend
the Bitcoins but he posted on Reddit or
some Forum I would love it if someone
would use Bitcoins to buy me a pizza and
so or no he sorry he bought him him I
want to pay someone Bitcoins to get a
pizza so he spent 10 10 000 Bitcoins to
get these two pizzas
those are clearly the most expensive
pizzas in history 10 000 Bitcoin
nowadays that I mean that's just a huge
sum of money so
um like probably hundreds of millions of
dollars
very expensive
um pizza but so speaking of sort of
crypto currencies as a store of value
and before we were talking about sort of
you know some people Divine defining a
sort of magic internet money
um one of the things that I think
everyone is probably aware of and
reading about in the past couple of
weeks has related to to
um FTX right so it's been very hard to
avoid the name Sam bankman freed or SPF
as he's known
um and for those who haven't been
following this is the sort of crypto
debacle du jour I think
um and SBF is the founder now the former
CEO of FTX which until
only a couple of weeks ago was sort of a
high-flying crypto exchange storing huge
amounts of value that
um has subsequently crashed and burned
and seems to be bringing a lot of crypto
down with it so obviously this is I
think a very complicated
story
um and I'm just wondering like the guy
who was you know FDX as you mentioned
earlier to me you know was just launched
in 2019 but somehow in this time SBF was
managed to position himself as the the
face of a new era of crypto respectable
that good guy and then I guess my
question is what has happened like how
did it Crash and Burn like this
okay so so yeah so this is um this is a
complex story
um but what we'll do is we'll start with
how Sam started which is Sam bingman
freed was a traitor and he had
experience doing you know trading in a
more traditional Financial venue and
then he discovered crypto and decided to
do trading in crypto the trading firm he
launched was Alameda research and then
about a year afterward in 2019 he
launched FTX which is a cryptocurrency
Exchange
now people should understand
the way a Trader operates is very
different from the way that at least a
crypto exchange operator should operate
and the reason is that a crypto exchange
is really
um probably at its core mainly a
security company frankly because for
anybody who's been following crypto for
a while or even if you haven't been
you'll probably notice that a lot of the
headlines are about crypto exchanges
getting hacked the most famous of these
was Mount gox in 2014.
and then
um you know there was another one uh in
2016 called bitfinex and that story was
in the news earlier this year because
the people who were laundering those
coins were arrested and the um it was a
couple and the woman in the couple was
an amateur rapper who went by the name
Razzle Khan so that kind of stormed the
internet for a little while there
um but the point is that a lot of people
who run crypto exchanges understand that
they are constantly being attacked and
the reason is because as we discussed
you know uh Bitcoin was designed as
electronic cash right and if you think
about it if you lose cash you are not
going to get it back unless whoever
stole it or picked it up from you is
going to give it back to you and it's
the same with any crypto you cannot call
your bank or the crypto exchange or
customer service somewhere to get you
know to file a fraudulent charge and
have the transaction reverse that does
not exist because these are
decentralized networks and once the
money goes from one person to an another
one address to another it won't go back
unless you know someone sends it back to
you
so
um that's why when crypto exchanges get
hacked that's like a huge huge you know
um like five alarm fire for them
basically and so many of them they're
very conscious of security Now the thing
is like you know Traders they're kind of
they're a little bit they just want to
kind of keep making money
so the point the reason why I'm saying
all this is that what eventually came to
light is that
um multiple people first of all by the
way before this big debacle pointed out
that there's kind of a conflict of
interest here because Alameda was
trading on FTX and so since they have
the same owner are they getting some
kind of Insider information that helps
them kind of basically make smarter
trades and profit at the expense of
everybody else that's trading on the
exchange you know how does that
relationship work etc
so even before all this that question of
whether or not there was a dividing line
between the two entities came up
now
um the way all this got started uh that
you know resulted in all these headlines
is that in early December November uh
um a crypto publication called coindesk
released
what they said was a balance sheet of
Alameda from it was like from June now
um what was interesting about that
balance sheet so Alameda had this
reputation as being you know one of the
best crypto trading firms but when you
looked at the balance sheet one of the
tokens that the balance sheet was
heavily reliant on was a coin called ftt
and surprise surprise the reason why the
name sounds similar to FTX is because
it's the coin of the FTX exchange you
can think of that as sort of like
McDonald's coin or like Starbucks you
know points or whatever where when you
use it on the exchange you get either
Rewards or discounts or whatever there's
just a benefit to using it but the thing
is there aren't that many entities
around the world that like have a super
vested interest in having this coin
other than you know FTX or you know
Alameda basically because they're both
owned by the same person
and when you looked at kind of the total
amount that was in circulation versus
the amount that they had on their
balance that Alameda had on their
balance sheet it became very apparent if
they were to actually try to realize the
paper value of those coins they could
never do it because if they were to sell
all those in the open market the price
would crash
and so people began to realize like oh
wait Alameda is not on really strong
financial ground here and so
interestingly
years ago when the so I just saw
somebody ask what's a crash like when
the price crashes like you know if it
was like 25 it goes to close to zero so
back when FTX launched
um somebody named chengpeng Xiao
invested in FTX and chiangpang Xiao goes
by CZ he's one of the most famous people
in crypto because he is the CEO and
founder of the number one biggest most
successful crypto exchange globally it
has like I don't know 70 80 percent of
trading volume worldwide is just like
super super dominant and CZ had actually
invested in FTX back in the day but then
as the two as FTX and binance with
binance is the name of CC's exchange as
FTX and binance became more competitive
with each other
Sam bankman freed eventually bought out
cz's stake in FTX and when he made the
payment to buy him out he made part of
the payment in ftt tokens
so after this article by coindesk
showing the Alameda balance she came out
CZ tweeted hey you know we're we're
realizing like this ftt coin isn't maybe
the best coin for us to hold we're gonna
sell what we have he you know he said I
have 580 million dollars worth of this
and interestingly this and this is like
a pivotal moment the CEO of Alameda
Caroline Ellison this is like sort of
the moment when it all went wrong she
tweeted at him I'll happily buy it all
from you at 22 I it was trading at like
24.25
but all the traders in the world
immediately were like what's important
about 22 so they are all now trying to
see if they can get the price below 22
they realize this is an important price
for Alameda ncz by the way said no no
we're not going to do a back door back
room deal we're going to sell all these
on the open market do it like you know a
more above board way
and so Alameda and FTX probably were
trying to defend the price of this you
know buying a bunch of it to to keep it
above that price and you could see
because you know these assets are on
these public blockchains where all the
transactions are visible
I mean it's like it's just crazy to
think back but they were pulling small
amounts of money from all these
different like D5 protocols or these
different smart contracts and you could
see they're scrounging up like 5 million
from here 10 million from there like all
this money and
um and so people began to kind of get
worried also about what's what's the
situation at FTX
so customers began withdrawing and
requesting their assets from the FTX
exchange and this is why you might have
often heard the term Bank Run when it
comes to what happened with FTX because
the percentage of volumes they were uh
what's wrong with they were seeing they
just like shot up right and so they they
were having delays because like you know
just doing that just there's I don't
know it could take time right uh and the
reason for that is at least I mean now
we know what the real reason was but
um at a normal exchange the reason why
it might take time is because
in order to keep the coins secure
they're often secured in what's called
Cold Storage which are servers or
um you know computers that are
completely disconnected from the
internet and often in a place where
there's like a whole kind of physical
ritual with multiple employees to get
those coins because they're yeah I see
someone saying it's called air gapped
meaning like not connected to the
internet and so you know there's like a
whole ritual to ensure that no Rogue
employee is going to hack the exchange
or that hackers can't get into it
whatever
and so um you know when you're
transferring funds from Cold Storage to
what can either be called like a warm
wallet or even a hot wallet hot wallet
is one that's connected to the internet
it's more easily hacked
um exchanges typically only have you
know whatever they need for their
operations in the hot wallet so it's a
small percentage they keep all the rest
in cold storage and then they might have
these medium warm wallets where they um
they might sometimes be connected to the
internet or whatever it's basically you
know just part of the transfer process
so anyway point is
um you know that would be the reason why
you might see delays at a normal
exchange but FTX which what we
eventually found out is that and it
wasn't that they were like illiquid they
were actually insolvent they had taken
the customer funds and had lent them to
Alameda the trading firm and apparently
Alameda had some trades that went bad
they were in the hole and they must have
thought they could trade their way out
of it and so
um at least so far what we know is that
there's four people including Sam
Pinkman freed himself who and Caroline
and then a few other top Executives who
knew about this I don't know if more
will come out but it looks like they're
about 10 billion dollars in the hole and
so that's why FTX eventually filed for
bankruptcy and but one plot twist I need
to mention along the way was that
because FTX had such a sterling
reputation even like people like
researchers who you know study crypto
exchanges all the time they were
tweeting like the day before like I'm
sure it's fine like there's this you
know run on the exchange but it doesn't
matter and then the next day we woke up
to news that binance was going to be
acquiring FTX and that CZ and Sam had
done this kind of handshake deal
which is just crazy because it's like
the biggest two Rivals and then one of
them says that they're going to acquire
the other one and you know FTX actually
had a better reputation because it was
seen as being more regulated and finance
was seen as being the one doing like the
Uber you know regulatory Arbitrage type
thing so anyway that ended up not
happening because the books were so
terrible they didn't want to buy this
this sinking ship but um but anyway
there were many other plot twists but
that's the just hopefully people uh
could follow that I know it's very
complicated seems like good father for
your next book although it is all
playing out in in public right now so
um we've got a lot of questions coming
in from the audience so I'd like to go
to to some of those
um this is from or some variation of
this from a couple of Ted members um Deb
and Nicole
um
how does how does cryptocurrency convert
to actual dollars
um as someone mentioned about it's not
backed by anything so it's confusing
right so because it feels like anyone
can just make up money and the idea of
value gets cost so how does one convert
crypto into actual dollars
so any of these exchanges will will
convert that for you um as long as they
list that trading pair
um if what you're asking is like how is
the price determined it's just simple
you know supply and demand so um that's
why the ftt coin uh you know the more
people that um were selling it the more
the price was dropping because then
there was a greater Supply but less
demand and
um you know I'll just say like let's uh
you know this isn't referencing any
um recent events but let's say there was
a moment in time like well actually what
happened back in 2017 2018 was that a
lot of people wanted to buy ether in
order to participate in these big crowd
sales that were happening and um so
during that time the price of ether went
up because the supply it was increasing
like a little bit there's a little bit
of inflation but the demand was just
increasing well beyond that so the price
of ether just went up and up and up and
it started at like I forget maybe like
15 that year or something and it went to
like 1100 a year later so yeah so
um given not just the FTX situation but
some of the other sort of scandalous
crypto things that have happened
um what kinds of
regulations or checks and balances do
you think can can prevent situations
like this in in the future and and you
know it seems
obvious that perhaps this the the FDX
situation would would at least put a bit
more of a sense of urgency
um on actual regulation passing
yeah so
um so here's something that's
interesting I'm going to actually say
that a way to avoid this is also built
into the technology itself
and um this is actually yeah some some
bits I wanted to get into kind of
earlier on
um so I'll talk a little bit about ether
and how you know we didn't talk about
how that's a different type of asset
it's it's also a crypto asset but it's
not a currency and I'll explain that and
you'll learn like what the purpose of
Bitcoin of ether of ethereum is and
through that we can talk a little bit
about how this technology could prevent
something like FTX so um as I mentioned
Bitcoin started as this cryptocurrency
and as people were innovating on it
vitalik buterin the creator of ethereum
he could see that what they kept doing
was they said they would say oh I'm
going to launch this new blockchain and
it has additional features to what
Bitcoin has
and he thought okay well if people keep
doing that then each new blockchain is
just going to make the one before it's
sort of obsolete so why wouldn't you
create kind of a different type of
blockchain that was built more around a
programming language
and then any developer in the world
could dream up any application and
upload it the way that many uh
developers nowadays upload their own
ideas for applications to the App Store
and our phones right now what would be
different though the reason why it
wouldn't be like the Apple App Store or
the Google app store is that it would be
decentralized and that's the the key
Innovation with Bitcoin is that it's
decentralized there had been previous
attempts at electronic currency but all
of those were quote unquote centralized
meaning there was a single point of
failure there was a company
or you know some you know entity that
was in charge of like making sure all
the transactions were happening or
issuing the currency or whatever it was
and that entity could also be then shut
down by a government
with Bitcoin this is something that's
just run by people all over the globe
it's not a company there's no you know
board or CEO or any Executives they've
never hired security to run the coin
Etc
um but the incentives built into the
coin will
um basically get people to contribute
security to the network
and um what I mean by that is you've
probably heard of mining
so Bitcoin mining is a process by which
people can kind of essentially win the
new coins that are being minted by the
software every 10 minutes on average
and
um what's interesting is those people
think hey I'm just getting this you know
money that's just being created and I'm
I'm entering into this contest to win it
but when they do that what they're doing
is they are contributing security to the
Bitcoin blockchain it makes it harder to
hack the more computer power you have on
that Network so that incentive was just
built into the coin you didn't have to
hire you know people an I.T Department
to like make sure security was strong
none of that it's literally just the
incentives into the coin got people to
make the network more secure
and so
um ethereum wanted to do the same thing
to have a decentralized you know uh
crypto asset but also now it would be
instead of a decentralized
um peer-to-peer electronic cash system
it would be a decentralized Computing
platform so you might have heard people
sometimes say that ethereum is a world
computer or whatever but essentially
it's a place where you know like I said
it's an app store where you can upload
these decentralized applications so
instead of only having Bitcoin you know
Bitcoin is um it's only like I said
electronic uh peer-to-peer electronic
cash
um now on ethereum you have like
I know you have like decentralized
borrowing and lending protocols you have
decentralized prediction markets you
have these decentralized nft projects or
whatever I mean there's just there's so
many different ways so in order to
participate in this sort of
decentralized economy right what's the
gating Factor right so I own some crypto
not much because I don't truly
understand it and and
um it was surprisingly easy for me to do
that through
um through coinbase I don't actually
have a wallet so but my sense is this is
still not something that most people can
participate in
well so
you're so okay so coinbase
um actually it does make it you know
quite easy to buy and sell
cryptocurrencies
um but when you do that you're doing it
on a centralized platform right because
coinbase is controlling the whole thing
and they keep their ledgers they make
sure that the amount of coins that you
have on your in your account is the the
amount like they're they're doing that
they're not relying on any blockchain
it's just their internal systems right
but but but that's the easiest way for
most people to quote unquote get into
crypto right so yeah you're going from
decentralized you're getting to the
decentralized Via something that is
centralized so when do we get to a point
when we don't need a coinbase or
something like that yeah so for people
who start by buying on coinbase they
would then withdraw to what is called
the self-custodial wallet or a
self-hosted wallet or
um sometimes it's called an unhosted
wallet and the host means it can mean
like someone else is managing your
private keys for you to make sure you
don't lose your coins but if you
yourself are managing your own private
Keys then you're the one in control of
the wallet you're the one making sure
nobody hacks into it that you don't lose
it it doesn't get burned in a fire
whatever that you don't lose
um the private keys or the or the the
password or what's called your seed
phrase
um I know all the you don't need to know
all these things but you can think of it
as simply similar to a password
um on coinbase your password will open
will open your coinbase account but if
you yourself are managing your own
private keys of your own crypto then
this quote unquote seed phrase or
whatever that just gives you access to
to your coin so you can send them out of
your wallet so when you are interacting
with crypto in this way where you're not
using an intermediary like coinbase to
do the transactions for you but you are
um basically using your own private keys
to initiate a transaction on a
blockchain then you are doing it in this
decentralized fashion and the blockchain
will often you know how let's say it has
one of these decentralized applications
on it that decentralized application is
usually what they call a smart contract
and you can think of it almost as like a
financial vending machine so if you have
a decentralized borrowing and lending
protocol on ethereum you know when we do
borrowing and lending the traditional
Financial world like you have to go to
the bank and you have to you know talk
to people and like people are deciding
are you what's your FICO score and are
you credit worthy and whatever
but when you do it in this decentralized
fashion they don't necessarily know who
you are um and it's not even a they it's
literally just a software program that's
been uploaded to ethereum or one of
these other blockchains got it so um a
question from Anjali um which I think is
timely um do you have a suggestion on a
sort of like good 101 to read on crypto
and Bitcoin and nfts
um like a crypto for dummies type thing
I mean I can give you some stuff that I
wrote
um yeah and some podcasts but but wait I
actually want to just explain how that
can
um prevent an FTX kind of situation so
um FTX like coinbase is a centralized
entity so because they were mismanaging
their books in this way and you know it
looks like also committing fraud all of
that is like you can't see that that's
just in their systems and even
high-ranking Executives at FTX had no
idea this was going on you know as I
said so far all we know is only four
people knew about this
if you're doing this um with these
decentralized lending and borrowing
protocols
um because the software has rules built
into it like you can't do those kinds of
things it won't let you because it's
just like a it's like a stupid software
you know they're called smart contracts
but in a way they like they can't like
think beyond the the rules that have
been set up so for instance a lot of
these lenders in crypto the centralized
lenders have gone bankrupt this past
summer
and it's because you know whatever they
didn't follow all the best practices but
was interesting to see is that a number
of them when they were going bankrupt in
order to even get their assets out of
any of the decentralized lending
protocols that they were participating
in
they couldn't access that money unless
they followed all the rules of the
protocol
so like none of this contagion hit these
D5 protocols there there was one which
we can talk about it's not a true D5
protocol but it's sort of a separate um
situation if you've heard of that like
just set it aside it's it's not one of
the core defy um protocols but the point
is that everybody was remarking that all
these centralized lenders were going
under and meanwhile all the defy
borrowing and lending protocols were
totally fine and all the liquidations
were orderly and everything was just
working as
um you know planned because nobody could
mess with it it was like the software
was there smart contracts were running
and you just can't change the rules so
so the technology is there so the the
the weak points come in when when humans
start to try and figure out how to game
it in a way so give it given that and
this is a question from from um from Dan
um you know is there a way to eliminate
Market manipulation if you have people
trying to pump specific coins
or specific crypto so for example as
10 member dancers like he gets the
impression that Elon Musk keeps trying
to pump Dogecoin or is it Doja coin they
never know how to pronounce it yeah but
you know is there a way to eliminate
that kind of Market manipulation
so that would probably more be more like
a regulatory issue because
um you know that's more like policing
the interim intermediaries or people's
behavior
um you know unfortunately I have seen a
lot of these crypto pump and dumps
they're it's very similar to kind of a
penny stock type World
um that really depends on education but
yeah something that's a little bit
disheartening to see is that some of the
worst crypto pump and dumpers they have
like the biggest audiences and you know
it's just people are kind of desperate
for a quick buck so I really think
actually it's more like Financial
education that's needed yeah I think I
read somewhere that there's almost 20
000 cryptocurrencies around and it's
just Beggar's belief that they could all
have any value
um so
um so given given all that's going on
and this is another uh question from the
audience I'm from agath
um with all the recent events in crypto
do you think that the the future of
crypto is is compromised
no no not necessarily I definitely think
that
um there's a lot of bad PR right now for
the industry and they'll have to kind of
get past that
um the main issue that I see is you know
as I mentioned
um I do think the technology uh has
built into it uh ways to prevent things
like like FTX
um and you know the sad kind of
situation that that has happened here is
that Bitcoin was actually born out of
the great financial crisis
Satoshi in the first block of the
Bitcoin blockchain he wrote a message
and it was calling out this headline
um about a bailout for banks and you
know this is January 2009 so this was
kind of when the great financial crisis
was in full swing and so you know he
kind of was saying like hey I have this
alternative to this kind of crazy
situation that we have going on here and
so
um it's just very sad to see that crypto
has actually created this whole world of
centralized entities that literally
mimic the existing Financial system and
so
um those are all the ones that failed uh
you know these past several months and I
feel like it's it's probably a lesson
More For That industry and for the
people in that Community to realize like
we need to go back to Our Roots we need
to look at more like of these
self-custody solutions that I talked
about
you know there's a mantra in the crypto
world not your keys not your coins
meaning uh people in crypto have learned
time and again if you are not managing
your own private keys and the person or
entity managing it for you loses those
private keys or lends it to their
training firm or you know whatever like
you like at a certain point you just
might have no recourse so
um there's you know I see a lot of
people talking about how they they um
are even like I had an entrepreneur and
I have this like premium offering and uh
he came on and did an interview and he
offers one of these self-custodial
wallets he said since FTX they have seen
triple digit growth and I was like wait
wait wait you mean just in the last few
weeks he was like yes so people clearly
understand now okay it's dangerous to
use these centralized entities
and even the I've had you know I had a
an owner of a crypto exchange on my Show
recently Jesse Powell he's been in the
the crypto space since like 2010 or 2011
or something and I asked him well you
know for you that's not good for your
business right and he was like no no no
no once people buy their coins I'm not
making any money holding it on my
exchange for them and in fact it's a
security risk for us it just creates
more enticement for hackers so I want
people to move their money to their own
wallets so
um yeah we'll we'll see if that happens
but frankly it'll probably be
um a lot of Regulation as well and the
one unfortunate thing about regulation
is that all the current regulations
they are built assuming that there is an
intermediary
so there is a risk that the regulations
that they propose here will be ones that
kind of force crypto to have more
intermediaries which again would create
the setup that caused
crypto I'm sorry say that again that
defeats the purpose of crypto yeah
according to what crypto people believe
yeah but like I said those are kind of
the hardcore people there's plenty of
other people in crypto who are just they
just want to buy their Dogecoin to have
the price go up so how do we how do you
think we get from a point where so for
most people I think the predominant view
of crypto is that it's it's an asset or
a currency right you speculate how do
you move from
the general public sort of thinking
about it in that way to some of what
you're thinking about in terms of crypto
writ large and the utility that will
come from that right so that theorem is
like a new world computer so how do you
go from crypto just being like
a store of value to
something totally different
yeah this is why so often people ask me
um you know either like should I invest
or how should I invest in and I always
say no no no think of it this way
don't think about just putting your
money on something and passively waiting
for it to go up think about your
investment as being one of education so
let's say you you know how you would be
willing to spend like 100 bucks on a
course about crypto instead you can take
that 100 and you can say okay I'm going
to learn how to make a transaction you
know send money to like my friend in
India or they could say
um I'm going to use uh part of this
money also to Mint an nft learn how to
Mint an nft I'm going to buy an nft and
then sell it I'm going to participate in
a decentralized autonomous organization
or this group of people who are kind of
affiliated with a particular coin and
vote on one of their proposals using my
tokens or I'm going to you know use one
of these D5 borrowing and lending
protocols and then use that to like
educate yourself on how to use this
technology
and yeah I agree with with you it's a
big hurdle because it's a completely
different Paradigm from what we're used
to
however already I feel like we're
noticing that people are in their own
way getting it when when they are really
motivated and what's fascinating is this
whole nft craze in the last few years
this is the first time where items have
been denominated in their in the native
cryptocurrency so you know for the
longest time like everyone would pay
attention to the Bitcoin price in
dollars to The Ether price in dollars
right okay these nfts that have become
very popular the price of them is
denominated in eth or Saul which is
Solana this other blockchain that kind
of sort of competes with ethereum but
it's a little bit different
um they're not denominated in dollars so
people are talking about the what they
call the floor price meaning like the
cheapest version of the NF team that's
denominated in ether right and you yeah
sorry and but here's the other thing is
that those people they're learning how
to use wallets because they want to own
their nfts so again once they're
motivated then they kind of you know
have to learn I will say for myself I
have to kind of learn by doing or I find
this very hard to to to understand so
um another question from one of the Ted
members this is from Vanessa or a
variation on on her question is
um you know you're talking about
exchanges right so do you envisage a
world where we'll have sort of one
centralized digital currency sort of and
you're not comparing it to Fiat or is it
that fit you know pounds euros dollars
disappear and where it's Bitcoin to ease
or Bitcoin to Solana and there's like 10
major digital currencies
not really no I think it'll just be like
the way we have email now but we also
still have the Postal Service
um it's it's just you know more options
I mean like you know like if you look at
yeah the stock exchange or whatever I
mean there's just so many different
kinds of financial assets and I think
it's going to be the same like if I
think about how the internet has changed
my life
you know back in uh I think was 1993
when I got my first email account
um you know I first of all barely knew
how to even check that
um right but now I wake up I check my
text messages my WhatsApp my like three
different email accounts or four really
um my signal my
um telegram you know Instagram Twitter I
have tons of Twitter DMs like I check
all those and I think it's going to be
the same way for financial transactions
I think in the future we're gonna wake
up and we're gonna be like oh you know
um I guess this Dow you know passed this
proposal that I voted in and oh also now
you know someone has a bid on my nft or
you know what I don't know I'm making it
up because it's probably definitely not
going to look like what I just said but
what I'm saying is we will have a lot
more things like that that will be
Financial not just communication like
you know our current Internet
and for those who don't know um a dow is
a decentralized autonomous organization
correct yeah but basically can you
explain that really briefly
Yeah so basically it's a group of people
who are kind of loosely bonded around
this one coin that they all own and the
organization has some kind of mission it
can be anything you might have heard
about Constitution now uh was that a
year ago I literally did just this whole
crypto world's so crazy but
um whenever that was that spring up like
kind of overnight you know is in the
span of a week they had raised
um I'm blanking I think it was like uh
close to 50 million to bid on a copy of
the Constitution that was being
auctioned off at Sotheby's and I mean
you cannot do that with like the normal
banking system I don't know if you ever
tried to send like you know like I I
have you know my business checking and
my personal checking sometimes sending
money between my own two accounts it
takes like a week
so to raise 50 million dollars not about
you can only do that with like yeah
ether and stable coins and Bitcoin or
whatever so
um so anyway the point is so there's
that kind of Dao you know but there are
other kinds of dowels where like
I don't know they they have like some
nft project or there's other Dows where
all they do is kind of manage these
borrowing and lending protocols there's
also these like mini Dows where they're
kind of like little Financial investment
clubs of just friends where
um they you know have this little token
that represents their membership but
then maybe like Simone and I are in the
same kind of friends investment club
right so maybe I know all about nfts and
I'm like really good at you know making
money with nfts but she's really good at
like doing defy you know trading or
whatever so we agree that everybody in
the club will benefit from the returns
of everyone will share it all but like
you know the group now benefits from my
expertise and entities and her benefit
and her expertise in defy
um and so there's just all different
kinds of downs so you mentioned um
stable coins just then in there
somewhere um can you just give a brief
description for for the audience of what
a stable coin is versus you know Bitcoin
or eth yeah it's any coin whose value is
pegged to some other existing assets
such as uh in the case of like you know
some huge percentage of stable coins the
US dollar
um so for the people the people who are
sort of crypto curious let's call them
um do you think now is a good time to to
dive in and and if so sort of you know
what's the most important thing to take
into consideration and and and how would
you do it
um I think it's a good time to dive in
frankly because since there's been this
crash it's a less speculative period and
what happens is during the big manias a
lot of people get their money stolen
because all the Predators are are out
there trying to steal people's coins
when they're not thinking and they're
they're just like I want to get in on
this deal and make a lot of money so a
lot of the uh the Fishers and um yeah
the other people trying to hack your
coins are out there not that they're not
out there right now they are it's just
it's not as bad
um but to that end the number one thing
I would say you should do at first is
learn how to secure your own coins
so
um and and what I should say is it's not
even like learning it's also deciding
what works best for you
because yes we have talked now about the
pitfalls of keeping your coins on an
exchange however
you know I don't know about you but I
lose things all the time and there are
many many famous examples of people who
they had some huge amount of money on a
device that they were controlling the
most famous of these was somebody who
was featured in this New York Times
article where he had hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of bitcoin on
some device and it was a special
security device where it only gave him
10 tries to open it and
um he was on his eighth attempt at the
password and it wasn't opening it and so
he was like sweating bullets because if
he you know got to the 10th try and it
didn't open the wallet then he would
lose hundreds of millions of dollars
worth of bitcoin so when you decide how
you're going to secure your coins
yes understand the pitfalls of putting
it on an exchange but also understand
the pitfalls of try to manage it
yourself there are so many ways that can
go wrong you can be fished of that money
you can lose the device people have
thrown them away
um you can lose your forget your
password or lose it I mean there's just
so many ways this even go wrong so it
all sounds it all sounds terrifying I
mean I I think you know so you're
basically saying I should move my coins
out of coinbase but
to set up a wallet but I can't lose a
piece of paper with the 10 words on it
that that I print out yeah however what
I will say so earlier when I said I had
someone on my uh premium offering who
talked about how his wallet was uh
seeing much greater adoption just the
last few weeks the reason is that that
wallet and there's all multiple like
this I'm not gonna you know say this is
the only one um but that one is called
Zengo
um there's some others which I'm I'm not
fully you know I don't know what the
fullest is but um they're basically
called
multi-party computational
um yeah MPC just MPC uh self-hosted
wallets and um the reason is they don't
use things like your seed phrase it's
not as easy to like lose
um either you know the keys or get
locked out essentially the way it works
is it uses you know a biometric aspect
um a magic link to your email uh just
other other parts like making sure that
you're actually an alive person rather
than the hacker showing a photo to your
device
um they have different ways of like you
know just having it not be uh you
relying on yourself memorizing the the
code you know the the um the seed phrase
or like remembering what the password is
or whatever so there are new innovations
that make it a much more user-friendly
experience and I imagine after this
whole debacle they'll probably you know
take off so so one of the keys in
addition to to sort of just better
education on this
um is also better user experiences right
now it is it's just
yeah I mean you know I I haven't as a
journalist I've been covering this for
seven and a half years
every single time I try to transact I am
so confused I can barely understand
what's going on you guys I like a few
years ago I'm not joking you I lost like
500 worth of eth in the span of like 10
minutes it was terrible what happened
was someone was squat so you can also
like a type of nft in this world is a
domain name so I was trying to get Laura
shin.if
somebody was squatting on it so I wanted
to like bid to buy it from him or who or
her or whoever and I per and I I didn't
know I expected maybe they wanted a lot
of money so I bought 500 worth of eat
from coinbase okay
the minute I get it into my wallet
there's something going on with the
wallet I cannot send the money I like
can't do anything and I was like what's
going on here
I don't know there it's like a
complicated thing but somehow they were
like two wallets that were in that
little browser extension and I sent the
money from one to the other and I
couldn't get it out after I'd sent it to
the other one and so yeah I just I lost
all that money and it happened in like
10 minutes and I was like forget I was
like forget Laura shindari I did
eventually get it
long story but anyway I will say that
this is not given me the confidence to
jump back into all of this at all that's
why you said just I think my crypto is
going to fester in my coinbase accounts
for some time
um so so I do want to ask one one last
question because we're gonna we're
coming up to time now so um
you did a tedx talk in 2018
um on Krypton it was called how crypto
could allow people to be their own boss
if you were going to give a tedx talk on
crypto
in 20 in in the the waning months of
2022
what would it be
um hmm
you know interestingly that topic works
I featured somebody on my show earlier
this year who lives the life that I
talked about in that talk which was
super funny
um and I I I have like never looked at
that talk except one time at some point
in the last year I did look at it and
there was a comment being like Oh my God
how was she talking about all this four
years ago and I was like oh yeah that's
interesting because now there is a trend
of people like doing all this and what I
mean by that is this person that I
feature on my show she's a recent grad
and
um you know she got into crypto when she
was in college and so she's like oh I'm
going to become a crypto founder so she
launched this startup
but as she got more and more into crypto
she's like wait
I started with centralized like that's
not what crypto is about so she kind of
stepped back from the the um the startup
and now she's just like a dow freelancer
basically and it was fascinating she
gets paid from these three different
doubts I don't know about now that I did
this interview in the winter last last
year
um but they're they all pay her
differently you know one it's more like
a regular W-2 situation another one is a
1099 and then the last one she gets paid
in their tokens and the other funny
thing is because it's this Dao the way
it works is all the community members
vote on how much they think that person
should be paid essentially which is
fascinating and so um the amount of
tokens that you get is sort of like gets
every month is determined on like you
know she has these interactions with
people every month and then at the end
they're like oh I think you know she
contributed this much or that much and
then that's how much she gets in tokens
so so so
um another member is asking
um this is Bob you know how does this
make the world better so is it that it
it gives us theoretically more control
over our lives
yeah yeah a lot of people talk about how
you can also use this technology to
um just it it subverts the whole typical
social media model where the social
media platform has all your data and
then they sell it to advertisers and so
you're you know as you've probably heard
you are the product but
um you can use this to own your own data
and then you can yeah be more in control
of so we are still the product but we
own our own data in a truly
decentralized world
we are technically still the product but
because we own the data we are better
off for it no no then you well kind of
but yeah you would be the one in control
of selling it like if you decide to sell
it somewhere then you are the one making
the money not not like the platform
like you you decide yet to sell the
money or to sell the data and then you
earn that money
right okay unfortunately we have run out
of time
um so uh I want to thank everybody for
engaging and sending in great questions
um you can all follow Laura on Twitter
at Laura Shin
um listen to her podcast I would
definitely read the book um the
cryptopians it is a lot of fun I read it
and I was really surprised at how much I
enjoyed it actually
um so Laura I know that everything
that's going on right now is keeping you
very very busy um but any final words
what's next for you a new book something
like that maybe
yeah I mentioned the razzlecon I think
did I mention that yeah
um so I will be coming out with a
narrative podcast on that and a book and
I will do something with the FDX thing
we'll see I'm not sure yet what that is
but otherwise check out my podcast
Unchained we also put out a daily
newsletter and a Weekly Newsletter and
you know we're on YouTube and Twitter
and everywhere so yeah just join us
great thank you so much Laura this has
been a lot of fun
um it's really great thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]